Payne is actually not a hot potato it's
a traveling professor and it knocks on
everybody's door and the wisest ones say
come in and sit down
and don't leave until you've taught me
what I need to know please stop asking
other people what you should do I think
because my career has gotten a little
more visible in the last two years
people are always like oh my god this is
amusing like how this like overnight
success thing need motivation that's a
top ten with a belief nation
she's Glen and Doyle and here's my take
on her top ten rules to success enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one allow pain to become your power when
I was 10 years old as when I first
started having painful human feelings
like fear and anger and unworthiness and
doubt and unbelief
are in our culture we only talk about
the value of happy shiny feelings I
thought there was something wrong with
me I didn't know that these were just
normal human feelings that everybody had
and that they had something to teach me
I thought they were something to hide or
get rid of and the amazing thing about
our world is that the second you start
feeling your hot loneliness the world
start showing you easy buttons to get
out of it so did you guys remember those
staples commercials where things would
get stressful and then a red easy button
would pop up and you could hit it and be
transported out of your pain into this
stress-free place well we all love easy
buttons right we all have them food
booze sex shopping snark denial now
everybody's a scroll scrolls roll right
the second we start feeling our hot
loneliness we're like you know what I
need to do I need to check on that guy
and you in second grade and see how his
trip to Bermuda is going
and we feel so much better right we're
numb but the problem is when we
transport ourselves out of our hot
loneliness we miss all of our
transformation because everything that
we need to become the people we were
meant to become next is actually inside
the hot loneliness of now right so when
we easy button out our way out we are
like caterpillars who jump out of the
cocoon right before we would have become
butterflies because pain is actually not
a hot potato it's a traveling professor
and it knocks on everybody's door and
the wisest ones say come in and sit down
and don't leave until you've taught me
what I need to know we have it all wrong
we are afraid of pain but we were made
for pain we need to be afraid of the
easy buttons right because the journey
of the love warrior is to rush towards
her pain and allow her pain to become
her power rule number two don't become a
perfectionist wake up every morning and
write all of my feelings and thoughts
and ideas and then I would send them to
my like five friends and these poor five
friends I mean and then I would just sit
at my computer and wait to see what they
thought about me and my thoughts and
feelings and if they didn't write back
right away I would ping that like so did
you get a chance to read my thoughts and
feelings for the day finally one of my
friends sent me a tutorial about how to
start a blog cuz she was like see honey
if you do this then we don't have to
read your crap every day at the same
time right for you to write so maybe you
could start a blog so um so I did it
just started writing on the blog every
single day and my rule was that I was
getting up at still 4:30 I would the
whole world would wake up at 6:00 so I
had to publish by 6:00 and I promised
myself I'd publish every day which I
think was a key for me because it kept
me from any kind of perfectionism like
if it wasn't good I still had to do it
creativity is a habit not a skill and
then and then it kept me from obsessing
like is that good enough is that good
enough
is that good enough rule number three
live your truth please stop asking other
people what you should do
no one ever knows what you should do
because no one has ever or will ever
live this particular life that you are
attempting to live with your unique
gifts and challenges and circumstances
and past and people your life is an
unprecedented and unrepeatable
experiment there is no path every woman
is a pioneer
you must stop asking people for
directions to places they've never been
because they don't know the experts
don't know the ministers the therapists
the magazine's the authors your parents
your friends they don't know but the
good news is that you do know there's a
voice inside of you that will guide you
and you must learn to trust it rule
number four grow through adversity so I
had my first rock bottom which was the
bathroom floor pregnancy test eviction
from my life as a drunk in a blima right
that's what rock bottom is to me it's
like an eviction from your life you know
it's whatever happens that you there's a
before and after you know so whether
it's like it's a diagnosis or it's an
announcement that you have in a marriage
it's whatever it is that divides your
life and it before and after so so the
first one was the bathroom floor in the
pregnancy test and then the second one
after that first when I got married and
had the baby and had two more babies and
became this like a grown-up a vertical
person that I was just amazed like an
upstanding citizen
I guess about ten years into our
marriage and Craig revealed to me I was
clueless about this but he revealed to
me that he'd been unfaithful to me our
entire marriage so in the less of a
relationship way and more of like a
serial one-night stand kind of way so
anyway that is that's that was a big
huge truck bottom for me because it was
the most painful day of my life the
thing about rock bottom is and pain and
being evicted from your life is that you
live in the emotional spot of it and the
emotional spot of it tells you well
everything's over and
this is the darkest time of my life and
nothing's ever gonna be good again but
then you have this wise side of yourself
that's been there before and knows that
rock bottom what it really is is a
crisis okay so we all want to avoid
crisis but what crisis literally means
is to sift okay like a child who goes to
the beach and lifts up the sand and
watches over all the sand fall away
hoping that there's treasure left over
yeah so that's what crisis does it
sweeps into our life and it forces us to
hold up our life and let everything
follow away that we thought we needed so
that we can find out what's left over
right like what can never be and that's
why that's why people who have been to
rock bottom are the people who are wise
and kind and brave and able to laugh at
the days to come because these are the
people who know that the way this life
is designed is that the the only things
you need are the very things that can
never be taken from it right so fear
just go so so so it's sad for me that
I've been to these this in individual
rock bottom and um and marriage rock
bottom but oh my god I wouldn't change
any of it because I'm just not freaking
scared anymore also if you want to learn
from other successful women
entrepreneurs check out my 2:54 girlboss
series it's free the link to join is in
the description below you might want to
get honest with yourself I can started
doing this be a billionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
first of all you got to be open to
taking some risks and not being afraid
to fail rule number five be consistent
you start writing for yourself and then
you start writing first audience of five
and then you start writing for you know
probably a large lot Electra audience
and it's so funny because I think
because my career has gotten a little
more visible in the last two years
people are always like oh my god this is
amusing like how this like overnight
success thing so I started this blog
what like ten and a half years ago right
but literally the ten year overnight
success exactly ten and a half years ago
and I wrote every single day for two
years before anybody just said anything
to me about anything other than my
friends right and
one day I wrote this post of club don't
carpe diem and again it is a post I
would have scrapped I thought I didn't
think it was good my dad called me after
my dad was my main reader most of my
feedback is still is from my dad he
called me and he was like eat when I
about the today's essay right
this freakin essay went completely viral
and more than a million shares right and
it was like this teeny little blog and
then you know two weeks later I was my
inbox was full of letters from agents in
New York and two weeks after that I was
in New York City at an auction for a
book based on the blog but the that I
had never ever one time promoted or
tried to do anything to get all I did
was sit my butt down and write my heart
out each day for the small audience that
was there and it just organically turned
into the book and all the wider things
and that's how the nonprofit started to
rule number six get rid of shame I think
all you need to be a truth teller is
shamelessness right and I was born
without it I don't know where shame is I
can't find it I just never have had it
really no no I mean it well maybe the
first 25 years of my life
maybe that was what all the booze and
addiction was about shame but what about
guilt well I mean guilt is good guilt is
when you say I acted like a jerk and I'm
gonna change it like I acted in a way
that is unworthy of Who I am
shame says Who I am is unworthy mmm
right guilt presupposes that you know
yourself to be better than you just
behaved
it's a correction right I am better than
that shame is poison shame is I'm not
good enough I'm not worthy and shames
just an excuse
I mean also shame is so prideful right
shame is the same thing as pride
it's the flipside of pride pride says
I'm better than everyone so I don't have
to show up for life and shame just says
I'm worse than everybody so I don't have
shut up for life mm-hmm they're both
just denials of our common humanity
which is nobody's better than anybody
else
nobody's more ready to show up than
anybody else it's just that some people
show up before they're perfect and
before they're ready and all the beauty
and good in the world is done by those
people right it's actually a very level
playing field so anyway I just think
that pride and shame are for wimps and I
don't believe in them and so every time
I feel shame creeping in every time I
feel shameful about anything that's when
I know that that's what I need to write
about right right because things that
are on the inside
that we feel shame about the longer they
stay in the dark the bigger and scarier
they get we pull them out into the light
so for me that's putting them on paper
the second they get out into the light
there's so much less scary you know
shame can't handle light the second it's
out it just disappears rule number seven
be a love warrior you know there was
something in the book that you wrote
about when you were digging deeper into
the Bible about the idea that women are
helpers tell us about the discovery that
you made with the Hebrew word I there
mm-hmm and what that means and I came
home one night and so I went I picked up
my Bible which I hadn't picked up for a
while because I just was so mad about
all of it and I looked up the word that
God used to describe woman and then I
started researching myself right I got
an internet I got on a bunch of like
really reputable sites and started
learning so Marie interestingly enough
it turns out that as there doesn't
freakin mean helpful helper okay Ezra
means warrior all right Ezra means
strong and benevolent right so Ezra is
used in the Bible to describe really
really strong military forces god
herself and what so can you just tell me
how from strong benevolent warrior
they got helper
right wishful thinking like it's a but
because it was a bunch of men at a table
decide they were like well we have to
freaking get the laundry done okay so
we're just gonna say it miss helper
that's why you have to be at the table
that's why there has to be women at
every single table because if you're not
at the table you're on the menu
yeah right so um so that just changed
everything to me man I was like oh this
is not like God put me here as like a
freaking a love warrior that's where
love where your kinfolk like what God
cares about is peace and love and beauty
and caring for hurting people and so God
put woman here as someone who cares
about peace and love and beauty and
caring for hurting people rule number
eight figure out your routine also I can
only do creative work in the morning I
don't know why it's a really common
theme I can do business like when you
know after the kids get off to school I
can do business I don't do what I can
interview I can do work but I can't do
anything creative and I actually don't
know anything after I know all the
things in the morning I'm so wise for
like an hour and a half and it's just
all gone so I just have to like grab
that time and if I do that every day and
also for me creating and writing is is I
mean I would hope my kids wouldn't see
this part but it's like the most
important thing to me so I feel why I
like them also I you're nice I like you
you and you created them also so I feel
good about that oh that's creative but
for me to feel fulfilled like I've done
my work for the day I have to do that in
the morning and then I don't care what
happens after that yeah like I've done
all all the hardest things the most
important things before anybody wakes up
so the rest of the day is like gravy
rule number nine embrace life let's
start with your story and this concept
of brute aful which I know is core to
your brand
what does that mean beautiful okay so
well I guess the first one I figured
beautiful out was when I was ten years
old so I just kind of was a super
sensitive kid and I remember looking out
at life and being like
this is like yikes like this is hard and
scary and there's too much pain here and
so I decided to drop out of life into
addiction so I became bulimic when I was
10 years old
and I think addiction is really just
like a little hiding place right or
sensitive people go to hide from love
and pain right or from beauty and the
brutality of being human so um I hid
there for a long time and as addictions
do bulimia morphed into alcoholism which
morphed into all the other things and I
wasn't till I was 25 years old and
sitting on a cold bathroom floor staring
at a positive pregnancy test just
shaking from terror and withdrawal and
um I was so unfit to be a mother you
know I'd been lost to addiction for 15
years at that point and I just remember
thinking there could not be a worse
candidate for motherhood that me on the
floor shaky and still something about
that invitation just I'm sorry about
that pregnancy test just read as an
invitation to come back to life and I
remember looking at the at the little
positive sign and thinking oh I get it
like if I want something this beautiful
if I want to be a mother but then I also
have to take all the brutal stuff like
if I'm gonna claim the beautiful parts
of life and that means I have to show up
alright like vulnerable I've just show
up like without the booze without the
drugs without all of the crutches I've
used if I wanna be a mother I have to
just show up sober as me and that means
I'm gonna have to take all the pain too
right so that's when I figured out that
you can't have one or the other like you
can't have the beautiful parts of life
and not have the brutal parts of life
and rule number 10 the last one for a
very special bonus clip is show up
everyone I know who is doing good work
in the world
is showing up before they are ready this
I think is the secret of life that no
one really knows what they're doing so
the people that change the world are the
ones who show up anyway so just be messy
be confused feel unprepared and show up
now I've got a really special bonus rule
on how to be open that I think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
that's a little from just watching the
video to take an action here we go
question number one how can you turn
your pain into power number two where do
you need to stop being a perfectionist
and number three where do you need to
get rid of shame I love that part of the
book when you said this inner self and
then you are representative and that
inner dialogue and the representative
tells the inner self
I'm fine I'm fine this is what we
portray to the world mm-hmm we do we
have a representative self that's who we
send out into the world and I think that
there's a small window that we're
allowed to reveal if that representative
so on down that was script script right
like when people say how are you there's
five things you're allowed to say right
so it's not you like the weather you're
allowed to say like your scarf all right
I like your hair like this certain thing
you're not supposed to say actually my
marriage is in the air and I am I am
feeling really overwhelmed lately and
you know you're just not allowed to
actually say those things that you're
really thinking and there's probably
reasons for that right this is what
helps our societies - it's all not to
freak out but I just really believe that
there has to be a place for every woman
and every man to be able to reveal that
true voice
if you like this video check out the top
10 I did on marie forleo the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there start before you're ready
if you wait until you feel ready to do
anything meaningful you're gonna be
waiting for the rest of your life